[Music]
so I know that you are a big star Wars
fan so what was it like being on the
other side of the stage today uh it was
incredible it was I don't think I'll
ever be able to describe it just seeing
all those people and how excited they
were I mean even looking there's a stars
backpack and you're in a star where and
everyone's just so excited you know it's
just a happy place yeah I just I got on
that stage I was like literally I think
I said I was like whoa it's just so
overwhelming
did you black out like do you even
remember yeah I know part of me was like
is this a dream pinch my says there's a
dream yeah that's kind of in the last
two years of my life really wondering if
this isn't like when you found out that
you were cast in the movie I remember
Ryan telling me and I was just silent
for I think a full minute and he at one
point was like do you cuz I was just so
shocked right you know it's it
I still don't worry there are no words
yeah did meet your character safe the
first time Rose can you tell me a little
bit about her and maybe how you
personally relate to her yeah um so
she's part of the resistance she works
in maintenance and like Ryan said she is
someone who is kind of pulled into this
journey and someone who might not see
herself as a hero or someone who's like
a cool you yeah here's her so cool and
that's kind of how she relates to me
like I I I'm a total nerd and yeah I'm
really excited for you guys to see more
of her lastly it seems like you work a
lot with John boyega in the movie what
can you tell me about the dynamic
between those two characters oh how much
do I love John boyega he's the best he's
the best um we have a really really cool
fun relationship uh I don't want to
reveal too much so I'm not gonna you
gotta try you know yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
you